you know when you're dealing with
depression or treating depression
um it's very very hard sometimes to sort
out
um and realize that depression is this
symptom it's not a disease it's a
symptom of something else and
unfortunately chimney doctors treat this
symptom directly and there's massive
side effects so I'm going to show you a
couple things that I think are very
powerful to take away your depression
but realize the best thing to do is to
match a a remedy or a solution that
matches the underlying cause
I mean
depression come from many different
things loss of a loved one number two
stress stress of life like right now
everyone's going through a lot of stress
okay number three winter people go
depressed
seasonally because of the lack of
not just vitamin D but sunlight okay
before a pregnancy postpartum depression
not necessarily always a decrease in
estrogen it could also come from a lack
of iron zinc magnesium because here you
are you're carrying this this baby
inside you for a period of time and so
you're feeding this baby all sorts of
nutrition not to mention if you're also
breastfeeding it's depleting you of a
lot of micronutrients that need to be
put back that can make you very
depressed
number five very very important gut
dysbiosis you have some type of
imbalance in your gut whether you just
took an antibiotic or some other reason
that can severely inhibit your ability
to have a good mood
no sleep will definitely make you
exhausted and depressed I don't think
I've ever met anyone who has a ton of
energy great sleep and depressed at the
same time
there's definitely a connection and
number seven blood sugars whether the
blood sugar is too low or too high can
put you in a state of a lowered mood
which could include depression or
anxiety let's first talk about the most
important thing you can do
as a solution
to improve the majority of these things
right here and that would be get more
sun not to the point where you're burnt
but just exposure to light there's some
magical things that occur from sunlight
you have this full spectrum of visible
light that you also have invisible
energy too you have UV you have infrared
that's doing all sorts of uh wonderful
things to your body including helping
you build up your melatonin Reserve not
to mention the sun giving you vitamin D
which vitamin D directly will decrease
depression it's a really good remedy but
you can't fix depression with low
amounts of vitamin D there's mixed
studies in vitamin D I looked at the
studies and most the studies that say
that it's ineffective they're using like
400 IUS or 600 IUS or even 800 IUS of
vitamin D3 that's not enough especially
with all the other factors that can
block the absorption so you're going to
need at least four thousand five
thousand ten thousand twenty thousand I
use the vitamin D to create the change
that you need
now also from another uh angle the
sunlight can actually increase your
serotonin which does affect your mood so
sunlight through the retina which is
actually neurological tissue that's
connected to brain tissue that actually
has centers that make serotonin in your
brain and so with more sunlight you can
help produce more serotonin you can help
bind and absorb more serotonin and
increase your serotonin Reserve versus
being out of the sun now if you can't be
exposed to the sun because of winter
whatever get bright light therapy huge
huge results with bright light therapy
you have to get a full spectrum light
and about 10 000 Lux and that's the
light you need to put by your computer
and in the morning okay when you get up
if you're working on your computer or
whoever have this light you know shining
into your face for about 30 minutes
you're going to get huge results just
from that alone also realize that
cortisol down regulates serotonin so if
you are going through stress okay you're
gonna have to do something to reduce
that because you're not going to see the
benefits if you have this underlying
stressful situation going on
number two
fasting the second most potent thing to
raise your mood quick story I'd
interviewed this guy who decided to
starve himself to death because he was
so depressed and he wanted to end it all
okay so
he decides I'm going to stop eating stop
drinking going into his room and locking
the door
after the second or third day
he started feeling really good he didn't
know what was happening but he started
feeling really great he no longer had
depression he no longer had suicide
thoughts
goes on his computer discovers what he
just did was fasting
finds my video we do the interview
totally turns his life around because
fasting repairs your brain okay and it
can increase your cognitive function and
definitely elevate your mood through
various Pathways okay so if you haven't
done it do it because you will get rid
of your depression especially the
combination
number three a probiotic or consuming
more foods that have good friendly
bacteria as in fermented sauerkraut
kimchi things like that pickles or even
plain kefir ninety percent of your
serotonin is made by your gut bacteria
okay
so not to mention just serotonin but
also you have other neurotransmitters
that these microbes help you make and
your brain uses a lot of these
neurotransmitters your body uses a lot
of these transmitters they've done a lot
of studies showing the relationship
between people that are depressed and
having gut issues okay it's like one for
one they have gut dysbiosis which is an
alteration in the type of microbes you
have and the quantity of microbes and it
just so happens that one of the main
side effects from
antibiotics is depression okay
depression
and glyphosate which is the chemical the
herbicide in all these GMO foods that
were exposed to and it's in our water
supply
works by blocking tryptophan okay it
blocks tryptophan in microbes
well we need tryptophan to make
serotonin that's the only source of
Serotonin there is no other source it
needs tryptophan so glyphosate is going
to block that and then there's nothing
there for the raw material for serotonin
to be built and guess what symptom
you're going to have depression so we
have glyphosate antibiotics and also
decrease sleep will also affect higher
cortisol which will down regulate
serotonin
number four going on keto I mean just
that alone the combination between keto
and fasting I mean so many reports
people going low carb all of a sudden
they're no longer depressed they no
longer have anxiety why because ketones
are a mood elevator also ketones
decrease inflammation in your brain both
of these actions will make you a heck of
a lot depressed the combination of these
four should handle your depression
significantly there's other things you
can do
cold showers every morning okay huge
effect I'll put the research down below
but the cold showers are really good for
chronic inflammation for pain for
sleeping to increase your energy but
also people are using it to pull them
out of a depressed state
of course exercise will also help with
depression
and then getting more sleep will also
help as far as nutrients go vitamin D in
high levels zinc and magnesium are the
three key nutrients that I would
recommend if you had depression if you
had postpartum depression because you
were pregnant take iron with that zinc
and magnesium if you're under a lot of
stress make sure you also add the B1
from nutritional yeast because that can
actually ease up not just anxiety but it
can make you a lot less depressed if
you're new to fasting especially
prolonged fasting you really need to
check out this video right here